as we saw in other sections the machine
learning section provides an interface
where you can build pipelines putting
together algorithms based on the data
type that you upload now you would
upload a table that you got from one of
the previous sections for example in
rna-seq would get a table of expression
of gene expression and then you can
upload that table over here and perform
some algorithms analysis on that table
so as you can see the section of
selection the data type is missing here
but it's expected that you're uploading
a table so to upload files we are going
to upload a file I'm just going to take
an example file here actually find the
table
I need to make it in groups now I can
start
what I'm going to do is build a pipeline
with quantum normalization I can select
here if it's already logarithm values
and what the threshold is work one down
the organization and then I can do a PCA
and what I have to do here is I have to
again select if it's log or not and then
select the table position the column
position where it ends and where it
starts to cleanly beginning you have the
ID in the first column now we could say
and do end you have to remember again
that after the pipe line is created
you'll have to press the run pipeline
button and the run pipeline button will
actually start the pipeline
so you can see it started it's reloading
started now I can go to my pipelines you
can see that my RNA seek pipeline is
running and the machine learning
pipeline is also processing